bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débat et le reportage comme tous les
jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur
Public Sénat et voici le sommaire de ce
5 octobre le référendum peut-il
requinquer une 5e République à bout de
souffle Emmanuel Macron a annoncé hier
vouloir élargir et faciliter son usage
mais c'est un chemin semé d'embûche et
ce n'est pas un hasard si l'en parle
depuis 6 ans sans franchir le pas
souveraineté populaire piège
présidentiel machine à illusion
référendum mode d'emploi ce sera le
thème de notre débat dans une minutes et
puis dans TR quart d'heure direction
l'Afghanistan 2 ans après le retour au
pouvoir des talibans exécution sommaire
famine crise économique et droits des
femmes toujours plus bafoué comme
l'explique cette militante qui refuse de
s'enfuir tout ce qui compte en ce moment
c'est de savoir si ma tête est couverte
ou si mon visage est couvert si j'ai un
voile approprié si je porte un manteau
approprié si la couleur que je porte est
noire et ma voix ne doit pas être
entendue et mes yeux doivent être cachés
et je ne dois pas regarder les gens
droits dans les yeux et je ne devrais
pas donner mon avis et je ne suis pas
censé parler de quoi que ce soit
wou comment aider les femmes afghanes
faut-il discuter diplomatiquement avec
les talibans qui sont leurs alliés sur
la scène internationale on répond à
toutes ces questions tout à l'heure mais
d'abord donc les annonces du chef de
l'État hier à l'occasion du 65e
anniversaire de la fondation de la 5e
République Cécile Sixou
Emmanuel Macron ne lâche rien après deux
tentatives en 2018 et 2019 pour réformer
la Constitution il retente sa chance
dans la version 2023 il propose
d'inscrire l'avortement dans le texte
d'accélérer la décentralisation et
d'élargir le référendum une version
moins ambitieuse que les précédentes
mais qu'il souhaite dit-il mener à son
terme j'ai ouvert ce chantier à
Saint-Denis avec l'ensemble des forces
politiques représenté au Parlement et
avec le président du Sénat la présidente
de l'Assemblée président du C et je
souhaite que nous puissions trouver
collectivement les moyens de mener à son
terme ce chantier Emmanuel Macron veut
aller au bout de sa réforme mais ne
convint pas ses promesses Patrick canner
le président du groupe socialiste au
Sénat n'y croit plus je ne compte plus
le nombre d'intervention d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la réforme constitutionnelle
depuis les 78 mois de dans lequel dans
lesquel il dirige le pays donc voilà
c'est une nouvelle annonce qui s'inscrit
dans une forme de procrastination
généralisée on retarde sans arrêt moi
j'ai envie de dire monsieur le Président
allons-y même l'assitude chez les
écologistes sur l'IVG notamment déjà
voté par les deux Chambres l'IVG je
dirais on n pas besoin de le mettre dans
un grand texte ou de voilà je pense que
là pour le coup c'est lui qui a la
décision entre les mains maintenant
c'est vraiment de sa responsabilité
c'est ce qu'on
attend pour que Ben réunir le Congrès et
puis et puis faire en sorte que ce que
ça soit enfin une réalité les LR
attendent un pas du président sur
l'élargissement du référendum aux
questions migratoires nous voulons qu'il
soit plus explicite et surtout qu'il
s'engage la révision de la Constitution
c'est très théorique pour les Français
je ne rencontre jamais aucun Français
qui me le suggère il faut par conséquent
que il y ait une application du
référendum ça doit être utile reste à
voir si Emmanuel Macron aura la majorité
des 35è des parlementaires pour faire
passer ses réformes il sera difficile en
tout cas de rassembler les différentes
familles politiques sur des thèmes comme
l'IVG ou
l'immigration comment redonner du
souffle à notre démocratie faut-il
élargir le champ du référendum et
simplifier la mise en œuvre des
référendum d'initiativ populaire on en
débat avec Benjamin Morel bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes constitutionnaliste
maître de conférence en droit public à
Paris de P Assas et auteur de ce livre
la France en miette aux éditions du SER
Florent valiot bonsoir et bienvenue
président du cercle de réflexion léérie
et enseignant à sciencesp Bruno cotrez
bonsoir et bienvenue politologue
chercheur au CNRS et au cvipof Etam
tranui bonsoir éitorialiste politique
allez Benjamin Morel on fait un premier
tour de table Emmanuel Macron qui je le
cite veut donner plus de force à la
souveraineté populaire et répondre aux
aspirations démocratiques de notre temps
déjà avant de parler de ce qui pourra
être fait et cetera c'est un constat de
crise quand il dit ça oui c'est un
constat de crise alors après cette crise
je dirais qu'elle est pas nouvelle et
pour la relativiser un petit peu même si
on va venir il y a des vrais problèmes
dans nos institutions elle est
aujourd'hui commune dans tous les pays
occidentaux vous savez de la Suède au
Portugal et de la polne aux États-Unis
il y a pas un pays qui va bien ce qui
montre que ce n'est pas qu'un sujet
institutionnel mais c'est aussi un sujet
institutionnel aujourd'hui on a une
république qui qu'on veille passer à la
5e B à la 6e et cetera et bien peut être
fondé sur des points qui peuvent être
qui peuvent être améliorés h la
démocratie directe on va peut-être
parler du Rip voilà quelque chose qui a
été pensé construit pour ne jamais être
utilisé ça montre que vous avez quand
même des points de fragilité vous avez
par ailleurs une crise de la
représentation globale le mode de
scrutin aujourd'hui peut poser un
certain nombre de sujets si vous
regardez par exemple en 2017 16 % des
inscrits donne 60 % des députés vous
avez un sentiment assez généralisé d'une
partie de la population de ne pas être
représenté de façon structurelle donc il
y a des choses à repenser il y a des
choses à revoir après est-ce que ce sera
sous quinquena bah ça on parlera de
procédure évid procédure équilibre
politique y a toutes ces tous ces
éléments qui rentrent dans dans
l'équation le le symptôme de cette crise
démocratique FL évidemment sont les taux
d'abstention record à à à chaque
élection pourquoi les Français votent
moins on a une partie de l'explication
mais comment comment vous l'expliquer il
y a des explications optimistes et des
explications pessimistes j'ai lu
récemment dans sur Z conversation un
article qui disait que finalement la
désaffetion pour le vote c'était
peut-être le signe d'une maturité
démocratique et qu'il fallait
s'accoutumer à cela on peut défendre
cette idéelà non je je pense qu'il y a
il y a aussi d'abord une une un
affaiblissement de la parole politique
c'estàd la parole politique est vécu
comme performative par les acteurs et
mais elle n'est pas vécu comme
performative par les citoyens et à force
de
multiplier les rêves incantatoir pendant
les campagnes présidentielles à force de
comme le fait Emmanuel Macron avec une
forme d'acharnement absolu de multiplier
les regains les ressuts les
réorientations du quinena et cetera les
gens finissent par être euh per Surb et
puis il y a aussi une qualité de vie
démocratique qui n'est plus au
rendez-vous ça veut dire quoi ça il n'y
a plus de grande figure il n'y a plus de
grands débats et Jean-Luc mélenchant de
ce point de vue là est
assez étonnant comme comme homme puisque
là il vient de publier un livre de
réflexion on apprécie on apprécie pas
mais il essaie de de de réfléchir sur le
temps long mais qui a-t-il comme
contradicteur et c'est ça la grande
difficulté et donc je pense que à la à
l'affablissement de la la la vie
politique de du personnel politique ça
mêle aussi ce débat qui qui qui qui
tourne en are boudin mais est-ce que
pour autant Bruno C en France je pense
qu'on est plutôt passionné de politique
est-ce que les Français se
désintéressent vraiment de la politique
non pas vraiment c'est ça le le paradoxe
c'est que on est un peuple très
politique il suffit de regarder le
nombre d'émissions politiques qui sont
sur les chaînes d'information qui sont
quand même assez regardés le nombre de
livres politiques qui sont publiés au
moment des élections c'est vertigineux
le nombre de sondages qui sont réalisés
on est un des pays qui son le plus par
habitants et donc il y a de multipl
signau qui montre que la politique ça
intéresse les Françaises et les Français
dans les enquêtes quand on leur demande
est-ce que d'une manière générale vous
vous intéressez à la politique on a un
peu plus de la moitié des gens qui
disent oui oui oui ça ça m'intéresse le
problème n'est donc pas le manque
d'intérêt ou d'appétence pour la
politique le problème c'est comment le
politique parle à ceux qui auraient
envie d'écouter la politique et je
rejoins ce qui vient d'être dit la
politique a une image aujourd'hui qui
est une image d'être enfermé dans ses
propres discours dans ses propres idées
avec effectivement cette idée de la
parole performative on se met à une
tribune on dit des choses et donc ça
existe dans la réalité et c'est vrai que
les gens il croient de moins en moins
parce que eux n'en voient pas très
souvent les conséquences dans leur vie
tous les jours et le politique a
beaucoup de mal à expliquer qui raésonne
sur des des masses des grandeurs on va
dire qui va changer la vie du pays mais
sur un très long terme que des décisions
auront des effets dans 15 20 ou 30 ans
et les gens disent bah en attendant moi
je je vois je vois rien pour moi et donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a véritablement ce ce
problème et effectivement il y a aussi
cette accumulation cette cet
amoncellement de parole politique qui
donne le sentiment d'un débit de parole
qui ne s'arrête jamais et dont on voit
plus la hiérarchie qu'est-ce qui a
commencé on est incapable de dire est-ce
qu'on a un jour terminé un dossier qu'on
peut refermer en disant c'est fait et
puis on en ouvre un deuxième on a le
sentiment que c'est une suite sans fin
deou en permanence des Nau chti alors
vous parliez des des sondages Bruno C
alors justement il y en a eu un fait par
odoxa pour nos confrères du Figaro sur
le la loocution d'Emmanuel Macron
concernant la réforme constitutionnelle
on peut difficilement dire que ce
sondage est bon pour le président de la
République 71 % des des Français n n'en
on pas entendu parler déjà ça c'est le
point de départ donc ça veut dire que ce
n'est pas arrivé à leurs oreilles et
puis euh ça c'est le score le plus
mauvais depuis qu'il a été élu président
de la République de toutes les
allocutions d'Emmanuel Macron et puis
ensuite quand on demande à ceux qui
l'ont écouté ce qu'ils en pense et ben
là aussi le le le résultat n'est n'est
pas bon 63 % des Français ne l'ont pas
trouvé convaincant c'est évident je vous
pique la blague parce que vous l'avez
fait juste avant que l'émission démarre
sil nous avait parlé de punaise de lit
il y aurait eu un tau de un T de
réussite beaucoup plus important mais
c'est pas seulement une blague Florent
vadio parce que ça est-ce que ça
n'incite pas aussi un président de la
République à
finalement prendre à son compte des des
annonces ou des thèmes qui sont d'un
niveau ministériel vous voyez ce que je
veux dire pour raccrocher comme ça le
l'attention des Français c'est évident
alors d'abord il y a une désaffection
des Français pour les sujets
constitutionnel c'est en général pas ce
qui permet de remplir une salle ou de
faire des des pics d'audience ça c'est
le premier aspect finalement on ne parle
qu'un petit verre d'eau c'est-à-dire le
monde politique et les commentateurs
politiques deuxièmement je pense que la
parole du président de la République
elle est usée parce que il parle souvent
trop souvent je pense que en début de
semaine il était il annonçait des
brigades de gendarmerie et en fin de
semaine il annonce le renouveau de la 5e
République peut-être que les brigades de
gendarmerie Gérald armanin aurait pu les
annoncer ce qui était prévu au demurant
à l'orig et le président de la
République a préféré les annoncer
lui-même et puis il y a l'exercice du
pouvoir qui je crois se durcit de plus
en plus Édouard Philippe sur le plateau
de de vos confrères de France 5 disait
qu'il voyait un président de la
République qui de plus en plus
ministérialisit sa fonction et je crois
que le Président de la République a
décidé d'être sur tous les fronts parce
que quelque part il pense que lui seul a
la baraka et que lui seul peut sauver en
quelque sorte le gouvernement la
politique française et donc il écrase
tous ces ministres qui n'existent plusou
alors on va rentrer un peu dans le
détail de de ce qui pourrait être
concerné par une réforme cons
constitutionnelle notamment évidemment
l'article 11 qui définit le champ du
référendum on va on va le voir ensemble
cet article peut soumettre au référendum
tout projet de loi portant sur
organisation des pouvoirs publics
réforme relative à la politique
économique sociale ou environnementale
de la nation et puis service public qui
est concours ou alors ratification d'un
traité Benjamin Morel que peut-il
rajouter à la liste en quelque sorte bah
c'est toute la question en réalité alors
évidemment comme diraient les Anglais
l'éléphant au milieu de la pièce c'est
l'immigration l'immigration est
intéressante à deux titres d'abord parce
que par rapport à la potence du
politique le capacité à agir sur le réel
c'est un sujet quand même qui est très
intéressant on a voté 29 lois depuis
1980 sur l'immigration en moyenne toute
une toutes les trois ans la réalité
c'est que le problème aujourd'hui en en
matière d'immigration c'est pas la loi
c'est l'application de la loi pas parce
qu'une personne est sousocut que vous ne
pouvez pas l'expulser qu'elle sera plus
illégale si vous changez la loi problème
c'est laisser passer consulaire et
cetera donc donc aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que la loi ne peut plus et
là on rentre dans quelque choseation
d'utiliser rend parce que le référendum
vous comprenez la loi elle va être plus
forte sauf qu'en réalité elle a la même
valeur juridique le droit européen est
toujours a-udessus et c'est pas parce
que vous allez arriver avec votre loi
voté par référendum devant le
gouvernement d'Alger en disant je ve je
veux me laisser passer consulairire que
vous les aurez donc en réalité là on est
dans une sorte de course à l'échalote on
n'arrive plus à faire croire aux
politique et on dit du coup référendum
égal effectivité ce qui n'est pas le cas
ensuite ça va poser des problèmes parce
l'immigration c'est pas un thème
l'immigration c'est un sujet de
référendum qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière
un référendum sur l'immigration donc ça
ne doit pas rentrer dans la
Constitution ça dépend les domaines qui
sont impactés vous faites un référendum
sur par exemple l'immigration économique
actuellement c'est possible politique
économique et sociale de la nation si
vous touchez à la pénalisation d'entrée
sur le territoire vous êtes sur le droit
pénal on peut mettre le droit pénal va
falloir également accepter des
référendum sur et bien par exemple le
l'excuse de minorité ça pourrait arriver
si jamais vous touchez au condition de
la nationalité vous toucher au droits
civil on peut le rajouter faut également
on accepte également des référendums sur
la GPA est-ce qu'on ouvre tout oou
est-ce qu'on ouvre certains domaines si
on ouvre certains domaines qu'est-ce que
ça implique du point de vue de
l'évolution du champ du référendum ce
débat on l'a pas aujourd'hui vous avez
des gens qui vous disent un référendum
sur l'immigration mais le référendum sur
l'immigration il fait pas une réforme
constitutionnelle et là en effet il y a
loin de la coupe au lèvre et puis ou
mais une question est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que du coup comme vous le
dites on n pas du tout de vision à long
terme qu'on est purement dans de la
tactique politique sur l'histoire du
référendum sur l'immigration avec un
appel à à LR et que du coup on oublie
toute la faisabilité de la réforme
constitutionnelle et du sens que ça la
réalité c'est que beaucoup de choses
qu'il a annoncé hier sur le référendum
je ne vois pas comment on les met en
forme juridiquement par exemple quand il
dit on va pas pouvoir revenir sur une
loi après un certain temps il prend le
traité de Lisbonne bon exemple en effet
il y a une frustration démocratique très
bien problème c'est que le traité 2005
référendum et la la loi va contre le le
résultat du référ quoi 2 ans après
exactement mais l'exemple est très
mauvais parce qu'en réalité c'est le
constituant qui revient sur l' viis du
référendum donc le fait que le Parlement
ne puisse pas revenir dessus c'est hors
sujet par ailleurs c'est pas le même
traité moi je bien juridiquement qu'on
se dise évidemment c'est un peu les
mêmes dispositions oui mais c'est pas le
même traité qu'est-ce que vous appelez
le Parlement ne peut pas revenir sur ce
qu'a décidé le peuple vous voyez que ces
idéeslà je les comprends elles sont
cohérentes et en effet ça c'est le
vraiment le symptôme d'une vraie crise
politique mais la mise en forme
juridique visiblement elle était très
très loin de l'esprit du Président je
reste sur le l'hypothèse d'un d'un
référendum sur l'immigration Bruno
cottres imaginons la campagne la
campagne électorale enfin le pays est
déjà clivé ça va pas s'arranger quoi il
y a aussi ce risque qui est un risque
social d'une certaine façon sociétale
oui c'est un peu des toujours un des
risques du référendum puisque le
référendum par nature va dramatiser un
choix entre deux options donc pour le
meilleur par exemple les deux
référendums sur l'Europe traiter de
Maastrich 92 et traité constitutionnel
2005 ont donné lieu à de très beaux
débats démocratiques on peut vraiment
dire que nous avons débattu en France
sur la question de l'intégration
européenne et de la souveraineté
nationale à ce moment-là et c'est vrai
que tout le monde a souligné la qualité
de ces campagnes malgré le choix binaire
qui ce qui se ferait mais alors c'est
vrai que sur un sujet qui lui est
hautement investi par les forces
politiques qui clivent à l'intérieur du
du du pays alors que le Président de la
République ne cesse d'en appeler à la
concorde nationale à l'unité des des
Français c'est vrai que là on voit un
peu le la contradiction entre les entre
les deux entre les deux termes et et par
ailleurs par ailleurs c'est vrai que la
mise en œuvre d'un référendum sur cette
question pose tellement de questions
c'est-à-dire quelle est la question
quelle est la question qui rédige cette
question euh est-ce que la rédaction de
cette question fait même l'objet d'un
débat
euh quels sont les le le chef de l'État
avait à un moment donné envisager
peut-être un référendum sur différents
sujets est-ce que c'est à l'intérieur
d'illeurs de plusieurs sujets plusieurs
thèmes voilà de plusieurs thèmes estce
que que là-dessus donc voilà tout un tas
de tout un tas de problèmes qui sont des
problèmes absolument absolument sérieux
quand on fait un référendum sur
l'adoption d'un traité européen bah
évidemment la la question est assez
assez simple le traité nous est donné
par les institutions européennes il faut
le soumettre à la votation populaire par
contre là c'est vrai que l'angle choisi
pour un référendum sur l'immigration
pourrait en dire on pourra avoir vra
de très lourd très difficile très long
conflit d'interprétation sur cette
question alors réforme constitutionnelle
on en parle tout de suite avec Mathias
AR qui va nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
bonsoir Mathias bienvenue à vous on va
parler de la faisabilité de la réforme
et
donc le nom alors on va pas donné de
pourcentage mais les chances de voir
aboutir une telle réforme c'est ça bien
comme Emmanuel Macron veut conduire
plusieurs réformes constitutionnelles en
une Thomas le chef de l'État n'a
pratiquement d'autre choix que de passer
par un congrès à Versailles en présence
des deux assemblées alors pour obtenir
gain de cause le projet doit être voté
par les 3/5e du Parlement soit environ
555 voix alors on sort notre petite
calculette Thomas côté Assemblée
nationale et bien il y a 170 députés
Renaissance 51 députés modem 30 députés
horizon ce qui nous fait un total de
251 députés alors côté Sénat ensuite 22
sénateurs Renaissance 18 sénateurs les
indépendants apparentés horizon pour la
plupart et 56 sénateurs Union centriste
dans l'option la plus optimiste ça nous
fait un total donc de 96 sénateurs au
total
347 parlementaires sur le papier qui
pourraient soutenir cette réforme
constitutionnelle 381 on va dire avec
une marge d'erreur de 10 % c'est
totalement insuffisant oui on est très
loin du compte il va devoir donc le
président de la République faire des
concessions aux différentes forces
politiques on commence par la gauche
qu'est-ce qui peut promettre à la gauche
alors parmi les arguments auxquels la
gauche pourrait être sensible il y a
cette volonté du chef de l'État de
faciliter les référendums d'initiative
partagé ou de constitutionnaliser l'IVG
vous en avez parlé cette dernière est
une demande de longue date de la gauche
mais qui semble trouver
portecloseuse c'est le président de la
République qui a la main pour avancer
c'est pas nous donc c'est facile de dire
je suis pour mais quand après vous
faites rien ça fait un an qu'il aurait
pu déposer un projet de loi
constitutionnel sur ce sujet tout tout
le monde n'attend que lui donc qu'il le
fasse même réponse de la gauche du Sénat
je vous lis simplement la première
phrase du communiqué de presse de
Laurence Rossignol sénatrice socialiste
très investie sur cette question
monsieur le Président cessz de nous
prendre pour des quiches je pense que
c'est assez clair est-ce qu'il a plus de
chambre de chance avec sa jambe droite
on va dire ça comme ça Emmanuel Macron a
prononcé des mots qui plaisent ici à la
majorité sénatoriale décentralisation et
extension du champ de compétence du
référendum notamment sur la question de
l'immigration mais prudence prévient
Bruno président du groupe LR ici au
Sénat je connais l'abîme qu'il peut y
avoir entre les déclarations les mots
les discours d'émanuel Macron et le
passage à l'acte Emmanuel Macron peut
pas nous balader pendant des mois comme
il peut s'apprêter à le faire s'il ne
s'enagee pas parallèlement à utiliser si
jamais nous aboutissions à réviser la
Constitution sur ce point précis de
l'élargissement du périmètre des sujets
soumis à référendum si parallèlement il
ne s'engage pas clairement à faire un
référendum et nous lui suggérons sur le
alors même si le président de la
République venait à faire le plein sur
la droite sénatoriale Thomas il serait
encore loin des 3/5è alors autant dire
c'est une mission quasi impossible merci
beaucoup Mathias Florent va dit on va je
vais donner la parole à tout le monde
sur ce sur cette expression Mission
Impossible pourquoi on en parle à la
rigueur je pourrais dire ça ce soir mais
qu'est-ce que vous pense qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez je pense qu'à nouveau le
président de la République relance
lesider parce que ça finit par être un
joueur c'estàd que il tente sa chance à
nouveau à nouveau et à dire vrai on sa
auprès de qui il tente sa chance est-ce
qu'il tente sa chance auprès de
l'opinion publique on l'a vu c'est raté
et le sujet n'était pas le bon oui parce
que il pourrait pardon interrompe il
pourrait alors là on est dans le cynisme
ou la stratégie se dire je vais faire
porter sur les autres la responsabilité
de ne pas avoir pu réformer la
Constitution puisqu'ils ne m'ont pas
suivi oui mais ça a déjà été le cas au
demeurant puisque la révision
constitutionnelle a déjà été entravée et
j'ai pas vu que ça avait créé un
bouleversement terrible dans le pays et
que sur les marchés on avait reproché
aux gens d'avoir leur parlementaire
d'avoir entravé la révision don personne
ne savait ce qu'elle contenait
réellement donc s'adressetil aux acteurs
politiques et dans ce cas-là je crois
que Bruno rotillot résume parfaitement
la situation on peut mentir une fois à
1000 personnes mais pas 1000 fois à la
même personne et donc je crois que
Emmanuel Macron a épuisé son sa capacité
de conviction auprès des des
parlementaires donc moi j'en arrive à
une conclusion c'est que Emmanuel Macron
essaie d'occuper le terrain et que
c'était l'anniversaire de la
Constitution il fallait faire quelque
chose ça était la Constitution la
semaine prochaine il y aura sans doute
un autre anniversaire une autre
initiative et il occupera le terrain ce
sont des paroles vaines comme la réunion
de Saint-Denis oui et il n'y aura rien
parce que c'est ainsi qu'il gouverne
depuis le début de son 2ème quinquen
d'accord avec cette idée un mot sur le
côté Mission Impossible pourquoi se
lance-t-il dans le dans le chantier si
c'est impossible voilà sans doute que le
tableau est un peu sombre là c'est clair
voilà mais c'est vrai que la question de
fond c'est qu'il y a d'autres problèmes
démocratique qui mériterait une révision
à ce momentl plus sérieuse de de nos
institutions le chef de l'État n'a cessé
de multiplier euh les euh les les
mécanismes de délibérer soit en direct
avec les Français avec la représentation
nationale ou avec les élus le grand
débat les conventions citoyennes les
réunions de Saint-Denis euh donc on voit
que autour de cette question qui est
comment revivifier le lien des citoyens
avec le politique et les institutions il
y a un vrai sujet il y a une vraie
demande dans le pays de ce point on peut
reconnaître qu'il essaye au moins il
essaye mais mais mais le problème
fondamental auquel on s'affronte c'est
quelle est l'articulation
institutionnelle entre ces nouveaux
mécanismes et les institutions
existantes et tant qu'on ne règle pas ce
problème c'est bien de faire délibérer
les gens c'est formidable ça va dans le
bon sens de la démocratie plus
participative plus inclusive bien
évidemment mais on arrive toujours un
petit peu à la même impasse qui est la
la tension entre la démocratie
représentative et davantage de
démocratie directe il faut qu'à un
moment donné il y ait quand même une
évolution de ce point de vue- làà parce
que sinon on va avoir on va un peu se
désespérer au bout bout d'un moment de
consultation qui qui terminine un petit
peu dans les sables à un moment donné
Benjamin Morel pour éviter le Congrès à
Versailles et les 35è des des
parlementaires il y a le référendum
ouais alors avant il faut quand même un
vote conforme des deux chambres he
c'est-à-dire que il faut que le Sénat et
l'Assemblée se mettent d'accord sur un
texte petit recul historique vous n'avez
eu jamais de réforme globale de la
Constitution quand vous avez une
opposition du Sénat et de l'Assemblée on
arrive à se mettre d'accord sur des
points typiquement le quinquen héonie
mais en règle générale c'est des points
très précis qui impliquent une
acceptation des deux forces majoritaires
au sein des deux chambres par ailleurs
vous a pas échappé non plus qu'il y
avait une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée nationale le seul qui a été
dans cette configuration là c'est de Gol
1962 il a le Sénat contre lui il a pas
de majorité absolue qu'est-ce qu'il fait
à l'époque le gouvernement tombe il
dissou et il utilise l'article 11 depuis
une décision de 2005 la décision chemail
on peut plus utiliser l'article 11 donc
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron est
contraint d'avoir un vote conforme dans
les deux chambres avec des oppositions
88 députés RN plus l'ANUP tenue par la
fi qui ne sont pas vraiment des
oppositions conciliantes donc une fois
que vous avez dit ça vous voyez les
chances amenuisées pour ne serait-ce
qu'arriver au moment où il pourrait
choisir entre le référendum et le
Congrès par ailleurs votre projet de loi
va y avoir quoi dedans va y avoir l'IVG
va y avoir l'environnement il va y avoir
la Corse la droite va être moyen
enthousiaste il va y avoir le référendum
potentiellement ouvert sur l'immigration
ça va beaucoup faire plaisir non
seulement à la France insoumise à
l'anupe mais imaginez la tête de Sacha
ouillet où est-ce que vous voulez
trouver vos soutiens tout le monde aura
une bonne raison de voter oui tout le
monde aura un petit quelque chose mais
personne n'aura de raison d'accepter en
gros le projet évidemment avec un
président relativement impopulaire et
dans une ambiance un peu de fin de règne
et pourtant on a commencé ce débat en
disant que queil y avait besoin de
redonner du souffle à à notre démocratie
donc com ou c'est un peu le paradoxe
mais mais la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui vous avez en effet une crise
profonde de la représentation qu'
nécessiterait mais ce discours éta
intéressant à la fois dans ce qu'il y
avait mais également dans ce qu' n'y
avait pas tout à l'heure j'aiévoqué par
exemple le mode de scrutin demande de
François Baayou depuis 5 ans demande de
la caisse totalité des partis politiques
sauf peut-être àair une loi ordinaire
pour modifier le mode de scrutin vous
avez pas besoin d'une réforme de la
Constitution c'est très facile non
visiblement ce n'est pas la priorité on
a beaucoup parlé peut-être chose inverse
mais qui est également dans l'air du
temps du cumule des mandats ou organique
possible on n a pas parlé hier il n'a
évoqué que des choses qui étaient
extrêmement difficiles ce qu'il pourrait
faire dans la la semaine il ne l'a pas
évoqué ce qui montre que là-dessus des
choses pourraent être faites sans
réviser la Constitution qu'on les vise
pas à court terme vous dites il y a pas
de de réelle volonté politique de la
part des Mar tu as vou intervenir
c'était ça ma question est-ce qu'il y a
même une volonté politique d'aboutir
quand on voit que par exemple il y a
quand même un accord du Parlement par
exemple sur l'inscription de l'IVG dans
la Constitution ça a été complètement
décidé à minima on pourrait très bien
faire une réforme constitutionnelle en
ayant la certitude que ça puisse
fonctionner en prenant cette version
donc à quoi bon du coup tout cumuler
comme ça sur des sujets aussi divers
ouais votre avis B c'est cl qui tente
peut-être effectivement de donner un
sens un peu plus large et peut-être
aussi que au vu des négociations parce
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
consultations avec les responsables de
partis politiques qui va continuer quand
même dans cette direction des
consultation avec les responsables de
partir peut-être à un moment donné de
faire une sorte de bilan en disant bah
voilà l'accord minimum sur lequel on est
et on va faire de la révision on va
faire la révision là-dessus
l'introduction du du droit à l'g par
exemple dans la
Constitution par contre c'est vrai que
l'écart à ce moment-là sera assez
important avec le propos liminaire du
chef de l'État qui est nous avons besoin
de
renouveler le ressort démocratique du du
pays je rappelle quand même qu'à
l'origine en 2017 lorsquemmanuel Macron
é élu pour la première fois c'est dans
un premier temps le premier dossier sur
lequel il veut être la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires la restauration
de la confiance dans la politique le
ressourcement démocratique et à
l'origine lorsqu'il fondent le mouvement
politique en marche le le le cœur de la
doctrine c'est de dire en France qui va
pas c'est pas l'économie c'est le
politique et au début c'est vraiment ça
c'est-à-dire effectivement réformer le
nombre de parlementaires il y a beaucoup
de réflexions qui sont à ce momentl
aussi sur les institutions c'est vrai
que ça s'est beaucoup étiolé de depuis
parmi ces petits qui sont nombreux mais
il y en a un dont la voie compte c'est
l'ancien président du Conseil
constitutionnel Jean-Louis Debray il
était l'invité de la matinale de Public
Sénat hier évidemment à l'occasion de de
l'anniversaire des 65 ans de la
Constitution écrite par son père Michel
Debray on est écoute l'ancien président
de la du conseil sur la constitution ça
ça fait 5 ans ou 6 ans qu'il fait des
annonces il annonce il annonce ça veut
dire quoi peut-être qu'il faut et je
suis pas opposé ouvrir le champ du
référendum mais
attention les constituants ont voulu une
harmonie entre la démocratie directe qui
est le référendum et la démocratie
représentat qui est le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale attention à ne pas
opposer les deux l'utilisation des
référendum depuis le début de la 5e
République montre que bien souvent nos
concitoyens ne répondent pas à la
question posée mais c'est une question
de confiance à l'égard du président et
cetera alors ne créons pas une
instabilité Tam tranui y a on vient de
l'évoquer pour Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui l'équilibre politique on se
dit c'est c'est quasi impossible de
faire adopter une réforme
constitutionnelle mais de toute façon
pour un président de la République c'est
pas évident oui voilà c'est un rock
c'est un pic c'est un cap que d c'est un
cap c'est une réforme constitutionnelle
voilà la réforme constitutionnelle c'est
l'acmé de tout mandat présidentiel
réussi pour cela il faut avoir du nez
pour dénicher des majorités l'exemple
canonique bah c'est la dernière réforme
constitutionnelle qui a été adoptée en
2008 sous Nicolas Sarkozi qui a porté
sur la moitié des articles de la
Constitution tout de même qui a
notamment instauré le rip le réfend
d'initiative partagé l'exemple de la
bonne idée qui finit en mission
impossible puisque RIP le rip jamais les
conditions n'ont été réunies pour qu'il
puisse être réalisé vous avez aussi eu
la QPC la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité qui pour le coup a
été largement employée et qui est l'une
des grandes innovations de cette réforme
on peut aussi citer la limitation à deux
du nombre de mandats présidentiel ou
encore la limitation du recours au 493
décidément des sujets d'une grande
actualité et cette révision
constitutionnelle de de 2008 est-ce
qu'on peut dire que il a eu du flair
finalement Nicolas Sarkozi on peut le
dire puisqu'il en a fallu he pour faire
adopter une telle réforme on l'a dit il
faut la majorité des 35e du Parlement
aller au-delà de ses propres troupes je
cite fédérer les forces politiques
au-delà des clivages c'est ce qu'a
expliqué l'entourage d'Emmanuel Macron
cette semaine avant qu'il intervienne
mercredi vous me direz Emmanuel Macron
il commence à en avoir l'habitude he
puisque à l'Assemblée il est bien obligé
de construire des majorité même sur des
projets de loi classiques mais pour
revenir à 2008 donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment-là qui a fait basculer
le le la majorité de mon côté vous
l'aviez hier sur le plateau c'est
jackques Lang jackqu Lang le poids lourd
du Parti socialiste qui a alors passé le
Rubicon devenant la voix manquante ce
petit bulletin qui a tout fait basculer
en permettant de faire adopter cette
réforme au Congrès de Versailles à une
voix près et qu'il a mis en froid donc
avec sa famille politique après Nicolas
Sarkozi bah il y a pas eu de réforme
constitutionnelle c'est pas faute
d'avoir essayé françois Hollande s'est
cassé les dents sur la déchéance de
nationalité des B naationaux une mesure
annoncée devant le Parlement réuni en
congrès au lendemain des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 qui ne revint jamais à
Versailles fautere d'accord du Sénat
tout comme jusqu'ici les projets de
révision constitutionnelles d'Emmanuel
Macron qui se sont aussi heurtés au
désaccord de la chambre haute mais
pourquoi ils tiennent-ils tant si c'est
aussi difficile on se demande
c'est en tout cas il y a deux
spécialistes de la Constitution qui ont
un début de réponse ils ont publié une
tribune aujourd'hui dans le Figaro c'est
jean-éic shuttle et Jean-Pierre CAMBI
ancien secrétaire général du Conseil
constitutionnel et professeur de droit
et voilà ce qu'ils écrivent ils écrivent
politique et groupes de pression sont
fascinés par la force symbolique de ce
verbe performatif qui est censé être le
texte de la Constitution qu est censé
hein oui on entend bien voilà c'est donc
la victoire politique par excellence
c'est à la fois souvent réussir un coup
politique un coup tactique en parvenant
à débaucher chez l'ennemi et en même
temps emporter donc la mer des bataille
celle qui restera gravée dans le marbre
de la Constitution le souci c'est que
disent nos aut et c'est ce qu'on a dit
depuis tout à l'heure si ce type de
réforme échauffe souvent les esprits des
hommes politiques elle laisse souvent le
reste de la nation je les cite assez
froide de marbre elle aussi merci Tam
tranui Flor madiillot ça veut dire qu'on
fait des réformes constitutionnelles
pour de mauvaises
raisons il peut y avoir de bonnes
raisons à une mauvaise décision et
inversement euh non je pense que il est
vrai que la révision de la Constitution
c'est l'héritage politique par
excellence parce que ça nous survit les
les successeurs ne peuvent pas le
défaire on a l'impression d'avoir
modifié la vie du pays et puis je pense
que s en France on a une forme de
passion constitutionnelle je connais pas
un président de la République qui pas
soit tenter une révision
constitutionnelle soit lancer des
comités constitutionnels François
miteran à la fin avec le doyen Vedel et
donc je je je j'avoue que je suis
toujours un peu surpris par cette
passion Constitution française et qui
qui échoue avec une constance assez
redoutable quand si on revient sur la 4e
République on parle de la 5e mais
permettez-moi de parler de la 4e les
constituants n'avaient pas l'idée de
faire la constitution de la 4e telle
qu'elle a été pratiquée il y avait une
belle phrase de Don Vabre qui disait les
constituents ont joué au jardinier ils
ont voulu greffer un rosier il ne leur
rester que les épines à la fin et donc
finalement et c'est là-dessus que je
voudrais rvenir on parle beaucoup
d'institution on ne parle pas de
pratique politique si on veut changer
les institutions il faut commencer par
changer les pratiques politiques rien
n'empêche le président de la République
de plus consulter rien n'empêche le
président de la République d'aller plus
au contact des gens rien n'empêche les
ministres d'être plus proche de la
population donc je veux bien qu'on
essaie de Revit is par la Constitution
peut-être peut-on commencer par les
pratiques qui un jour pourront être
transcrites dans la Constitution s'il
devait y avoir un blocage pour l'instant
je n'en vois pas et effectivement le
jour où on aura un blocage définitif on
pourra toujours exciper de la
Constitution ça n'a jamais été le cas
alors je vis qu'on se concentre
maintenant sur la question du référendum
d'initiative partagé on va écouter le
président de la République hier voilà ce
qu'il nous dit sur ce thème la
souveraineté populaire peut également
s'exprimer mais directement à l'issue
d'un référendum d'initiative
partagé cette procédure utile est
aujourd'hui excessivement
contrainte sa mise en œuvre doit être
plus simple et les seuils permettant son
usage comme peut-être ces procédures
devrait d lors être revu bon Bruno
cotesson va peut-être commencer par
expliquer pourquoi ça marche pas
aujourd'hui l'idée sur le papier est
intéressante effectivement par contre on
peut pas vraiment dire que ça répond à
la demande de la société qui est plutôt
du côté de l'initiative citoyenne là
c'est initi partagé c'est c'est 15/5e
des parlementaires soutenu nous ditons
par 1 diè du corps
électoralàà presque 5 millions voilà
donc on voit déjà du point de vue de qui
a l'initiative c'est pas en direct le
peuple qui peut demander bien sûr ça
peut être indirectement si si les
parlementaires voient qu'il y a un sujet
qui mobilise beaucoup le pays et cetera
bien bien évidemment qui peuvent s'en
s'en saisir et puis c'est vrai que les
conditions sont telles que pour le
moment on a vu Aéroport de Paris ça a
pas pu le faire on a vu sur la réforme
des retraites là s'est passé
différemment le Conseil constitutionnel
a dit ben non finalement ça ne nécessite
pas ça n'est ça n'est pas éligible au
champ de ce référendum d'initiative
partagé donc pour le moment ça ne répond
pas à la demande qui elle existe
vraiment dans le pays c'est c'est pas
effectivement parce que les institutions
répondent mal à une question que la
question est mauvaise il y a une vraie
question qui se pose il y a une vraie
demande de plus de démocratie directe
dans le pays il y a d'autres pays
européens qui qui qui qui s'intéressent
aux mêmes questions ou qui ont des
initiatives citoyennes donc voilà on
voit qu'il a un vrai sujet de ce point
de vue-là et qu'on peut pas rester
définitivement au milieu au milieu du
gay avec une demande du pays et des
institutions qui ne répondent pas bien à
cette demande Benjamin Morel double
question est-ce que il y a un seuil je
sais pas est-ce que c'est 1 million de
de de citoyens par exemple et puis
accessoirement est-ce que ça pourrait
pas porter juste sur ce thème-là la
réforme constitutionnelle
alors probablement que ça pourrait
encore fait-il qu'on se mette d'accord
parce que faut revenir à même làdessus
on aurait pas les 35e des des
parlementair en 2008 si on si on fait ce
truc qui n'a pour objectif que de ne
jamais être utilisé voilà il faut se
remettre dans l'esprit de l'époque on
est juste après 2005 et donc il faut
introduire quelque chose parce que bien
il faut bien introduire quelque chose
mais il faut surtout pas que ça serve
parce que imaginez-vous le peuple dirait
non au Parlement et ça c'est un problème
et donc on met un seuil qui est
totalement dantesque en Italie
500000 1 % oui est-ce qu'on peut pas
pays comparable Italie en terme de
population oui mais alors ça devient
presque un droit de veto par référendum
sur les droits qui sur les lois qui
viennent d'être voté vous savez 500000
c'est pas tant que ça quant au droit de
vetto justement c'est ce que refuse
Emmanuel Macron est ce qu'on refusé en
2008 il faut bien comprendre que
l'origine du référendum inititive
citoyenne ou partager c'est ça regardez
les cons montagnardes des girondines
sous la Révolution le Parlement aimait
l'idée de ce qu'il pense être la volonté
générale et à l'époque on fait pas de
référendum parce qu'il y a pas d'urnne
mais les assemblées primaires peuvent
lui dire non l'Italie c'est un
référendum veto vous voyez la démocratie
italienne s'effondrée plus que la nôtre
non vous avez des référendum veto un peu
partout en Europe l'idée que et bien les
représentants représentent mais que ces
représentants ne font que représenter et
que parfois et bien ils peuvent être
contredits par leurs électeurs c'est
quelque chose qui ne devrait pas nous
choquer mais on est tellement
aujourd'hui dans un sentiment obsidional
de la part des représentants que cette
simple idée qui a fait peur en 2008
contre continue à faire peur et au Sénat
et à Emmanuel Macron donc cette version
là ne passera pas mais vous comprenez
bien que ce qui est attendu par beaucoup
de Français après la réforme des
retraites et ce qui va être attendu par
la gauche à l'assemblée qui là-dessus
fera l'obstruction il y a pas moyen de
juguler l'obstruction quand vous êtes
dans une réforme constitutionnelle bah
c'est un RIC sur la réforme des retraite
ou un RIP sur la réforme des retraites
donc un référendum veto donc entre cette
vision qui a sa légitimité et qui
historiquement est fondée et de l'autre
côté la peur de voir justement les
représentants contredit trouver un
modusindice ça va être compliqué FL va
votre avis là-dessus est-ce que ce sont
de légitimités qui s'opposent d'une
certaine façon en tout cas tout a été
construit dans notre culture politique
pour qu'elle s'oppose puisque nous avons
longtemps donné le primat absolu à la
démocratie représentative minoré le plus
possible la démocratie directe et de
fait nous avons une culture politique
qui en quelque sorte estime que toute
tout recours direct au peuple et non
seulement contraire à la démocratie
représentative mais en plus plutôt du du
côté des bonapartistes des des des coups
personnel et C donc il y a une méfiance
du pouvoir personnel qui passe notamment
par le peuple mais moi j'ai envie de
dire quand même que le Président de la
République s'il organisait une
consultation quelle que soit la
consultation sans base constitutionnelle
qu'il avait un résultat comment les
parlementaires pourrai-ils s'affranchir
du du scrutin populaire il ne pourrai
pas donc encore une fois cette révérence
constitutionnelle Benj norm il est
constitutionnaliste c'est pas ça le
problème de la consultation c'est que
déjà elle est pas constitionnel pour
être organisé c'est le gros problème
qu'il aurait sur les multiréférendum et
le deuxième élément qui poserait
problème c'est que du coup vous ne
pouvez pas convoquer l'électeur et donc
ne viendrait que les gens qui aurent
envie de venir et faire plaisir au
président donc ça serait probablement
pas représentatif et ensuite aller
pourtre un moyen je d'accord avec FL
pour imposer au parlementaire une
réforme du ça sera moyen de mettre
quelque chose à l'agenda mais regardez
enfin on parlait de la Corse il y a
quelques semaines regardez ce qu'a fait
Frédéric Bierry en Alsace il a dit moi
je veux un référendum local sur la
sortie du grand il pas le droit de
l'organiser donc il a organisé une
consultation ne sont venus que les
convaincus le taux de participation a
été ridicule et il y a eu 90 % de oui
c'est ce qu'on aurait ouais
vous voulez peut-êre conclure làdessus
et puis je vous donne la parole non je
pense en tout cas que on pourra agiter
tous les trucs tous les machins demander
au parlementaires de mettre des ratios
il y a rien de plus excitant qu'un
chiffre dans une révision
constitutionnelle ou même dans un
exercice législatif ça ne marchera pas
tant que derrière l'intention n'est pas
pure et elle n'est pas tendue par un
objectif politique et on est toujours
dans une politique de gribouille
intentionnelle alors que là on ne voit
pas où il veut aller et finalement c'est
ça c'est vrai voà encore une fois un
problème qui que que tout le monde se
pose qui est comment comment saisir
davantage l'opinion du souverain le
peuple entre deux élections l'élection
reste le moment cardinal de la
démocratie représentative se compter le
jour d'élection rien n'est plus
essentiel mais on voit de plus en plus
qu'entre les taux d'abstention et l'
tion au lendemain des des élections il
faut quelque chose il faut que quelque
chose se mettre en œuvre pour stopper la
machine à produire de l'abstention et de
la défiance politique donc c'est le rôle
des institutions normalement de faire ça
de de de se saisir de cette question
d'une certaine manière le chef de l'État
est tout à fait dans son rôle de se
saisir de cette de cette question par
contre on voit qu'effectivement il ouvre
il ouvre le débat pour le moment il
reste au milieu du gay on va pas
jusqu'au bout de l'idée princi principal
qui est je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
comment articuler ces moments de
respiration démocratique consultation
votation et cetera avec les institutions
qui sont issues directement du suffrage
universel ça se pose au niveau local
également on a eu le cas de référendum
local sur Notre-Dame des
Landes là le peuple s'exprime dit on en
veut de de cet aéroport puis final
politique dit maintenant c'est pas
opportun finalement donc là aussi ça
pose des tas des tas de des tas de
soucis et c'est vrai que si on convoque
une seule consultation à voocation
consultative bah on a quand même un gros
problème des bases juridiques légales
Benjamin l'a rappelé on peut pas
convoquer juridiquement le peuple aux
élections et donc ça n' ça ça n'a pas de
base ça crée encore plus de désordre
dans la discussion oui globalement
autour de cette table tout le monde est
assez critique Florent vadillot
peut-être vous être le plus critique on
dit politique de gribouille mais alors
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
proposez pour redonner ce souffle à la
démocratie voilà est-ce qu'il y a une
mesure alors la mesure miracle je crois
pas mais qu'est-ce que vous proposez
d'abord cher Thomas je ne suis pas
président de la République mais mais
puisque vous m'y obligez non mais
vraiment je je reviens sur cette
histoire de pratique politique je pense
que dans l'exercice du pouvoir au
quotidien c'est une autre pratique à
faire le président de la République il a
théorisé le président Jupiterrien et on
voit son isolement les ministres ont
théorisé juste des déplacements encore
une fois il n'y a pas de consultation la
convention citoyenne qui était une
excellente idée elle a son résultat a
été sabré encore une fois pour moi il
n'y a pas de d'obstacle à la volonté
politique il n'y a que des pratiques que
l'on installe durablement de fait le
président de la République depuis le
début de son premier quinena a installer
une pratique du pouvoir qui est une
pratique finalement assez conservatrice
dans dans la droite ligne de la 5e
République golom miterandienne dirait
les les certains et donc moi j'invite
les responsables politiques à changer de
pratique et et déjà dans la concertation
dans la consultation dans l'écoute ça ça
amènera quand même sans doute beaucoup
de de de difficultés en moins sur
certains projets
Benjamin Morel même question vous avez
commencé à l'évoquer tout à l'heure en
disant finalement il y a pas forcément
besoin d'une réforme constitutionnelle
pour sou on à peu près dans ces grands
fondement la même constitution que le
Portugal ou l'Autriche ce qui change
c'est le mode de scrutin vous changez le
mode de scrutin vous changez la
République parce qu'en réalité donc de
la proportionnelle oui comment ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui le président est
élu derrière sauf la dernière fois vous
avez une majorité pléorique parce que
ceux qui croient pas au président de la
République s'abstiennne et donc celui
qui contôle l'éisée contrôle matigon
celui contrôle contrôle le Palais
Bourbon celui qui contrôle le P Bourbons
contrôle
on a une hyper concentration des
pouvoirs et un président qui vient
Premier ministre vous avez plus de
majorité c'est plus du tout la même
donne et là vous changez les mentalités
majorité de coalition pacte de
gouvernement et C exement si vous
changez le mode de scrutin si vous
décalez les élections vous faites
beaucoup plus qu'en trifouillant la haut
dans les grandes sphères
constitutionnelles mais évidemment ça ça
implique de changer de système quand
vous trifouillez dans les grandes
sphères constitutionnelles vous changez
pas le système vous allez pas changer le
système en ajoutant l'IVG ou
l'environnement même si c'est peut-être
important en revanche là vous changez
totalement le présidentialisme vous le
remettez en cause ce qui montre bien que
nos réformes extrêmement ambitieuses de
la Constitution en fait elles sont
fondamentalement conservatrices merci
beaucoup c'était passionnant de de vous
entendre les uns et les autres j'ai
rappelé Benjamin Morel le le titre de
votre livre la France en miette qui est
publié aux éditions du SER à très
bientôt sur Public Sénat